[Musique]
au sommaire de ce nouveau par soixante
dix huit l'invité une star du football
le génial vincent guérin gros plan sur
l'événement des balles blanches qui
s'est déroulé le 6 juin dernier au golf
du prieuré matériel le gold board ou une
planche de surf électrique pour jouer au
golf vautours sur l'open de france avec
le meilleur français mike lorenzo vera
et le vainqueur du tournoi
tommy fait tourner sans oublier
naturellement des conseils des pros
[Musique]
un show en compagnie de quelqu'un pour
lequel j'ai une grande admiration
j'avais une grande admiration pour lui
sur les terrains de foot c'est vincent
guérin bonjour bonjour patrice alors là
où nous sommes aux balles blanches parce
que vous êtes de ceux qui participent
des personnalités qui participent à
cette cette réunion qui vient en appui
aux en fonction hospitalisé et puis
parce que le golf vidéo pour toi aussi
pour vous
ouais c'est une pratique il a manqué un
peu nouvelle parce que évidemment il ya
la pratique footballistique mais l'après
carrière
c'est un petit peu évertué à trouver une
autre pratique et c'est vrai que le golf
est intéressante de ce côté-là ya trop
de footballeurs rouge oui à beaucoup ya
dix jours antoine kombouaré oui enfin
voilà et qui sont de très beaux arts
faire vous aussi un peu moins pour moi
j'ai moins mordu encore à l'hameçon que
parce que j'étais parme en permanence
mais c'est un ken pratiquer un sport
très intéressant et très plaisant
d'avoir fait venir un petit peu sur
bourg sur votre carrière footballistique
parce que évidemment je dis vous avez
été le héros de beaucoup de beaucoup de
donateurs de football et de supporter ça
a été un des joueurs emblématiques et du
paris saint germain et l'équipe de
france
comment c'est venu le football dans
votre vie mais très tôt très jeune
comme un gamin voit tout simplement puis
après on a été piqué par le par la
passion par le par le plaisir de
s'amuser
individuellement et puis avec les
copains et puis voilà puis à propos il
ya eu un petit peu de talent et la chine
y avait eu ni gros coup de chance aussi
et puis de guerrier alors qui vous
conduit la poule j sais quoi c'est le
paris saint-germain l'équipe de france
une demi finale à l'euro 96 en
angleterre
pour moi c'était important parce que
effectivement il y a
à 8,3 sur les onze main fait partie des
trois qui ont pas continuer l'aventuré
en 98 non c'est qu'en grèce et c'est
comme ça nancy j'ai un grand plaisir et
puis après j'ai été sélectionné dans
l'équipe d'europe et un match six mois
après avec les meilleurs joueurs de
l'euro je faisais partie de ceux là donc
ça c'était un grand plaisir se tasse un
petit peu un petit clin d'oeil par
rapport aux gamins que j'étais où on
faisait un petit peu des rêves
oui c'est à moi en tant qu'adulte alors
87 c'est juste avant l'équipe championne
du monde de 90 vous avez jamais regretté
d'avoir un réponse comme ça il faut pas
avoir de regrets c'est la vie c'est fait
partie
des aléas d'un parcours de sportif mais
moi j'en ai bien profité
j'ai cette chance d'aller vers le haut
niveau donc non je n'ai pas de regrets
par rapport à ça et puis on n'est jamais
de rien c'est à dire que l'équipe de
france 98 tel mais aussi de ce qui s'est
passé un peu avant oui oui bah c'était
un peu la génération 90 2001 on a eu la
chance d'avoir une équipe de france très
forte mais parce que les équipes de
clubs étaient très fortes aussi long
mais monaco café devient le de coupe
d'europe à bordeaux il ya une ou un fait
2 marseille en a fait deux dons il y
avait beaucoup de
oui très bonne équipe concert avec de
très grands joueurs c'est pour ça que la
génération 98 il a été brillante
maintenant que vous avez arrêté le très
haut niveau
qu'est ce qui a changé dans le foot
depuis 20 ans or beaucoup de choses ou
de web à l'environnement économique déjà
c'est vrai que financièrement
aujourd'hui les ne serait-ce que l'ailé
droite et puis les salaires des joueurs
n'ont plus rien à voir avec ce qu'on a
connu
et puis
bon bah oui évidemment fin on a bien
limité mais c'est comme ça je pourrais
lui dire il avant la génération platini
aujourd'hui 20 par rapport à nous notre
génération mais bon c'est comme ça ça
fait partie de la vie j'allais à et
c'est pareil c'est enfin malheureusement
ces facteurs de société alors quand on
est un sportif de très haut niveau comme
vous évidemment se pose le problème de
la reconversion
mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire après ah
ouais vous avez travaillé dans le foot
vous avez été entraîneur notamment de
l'équipe réserve n'est pas seulement la
laisser à jamais avec de très bons
joueurs vous avez amené des gens comme
ça coup comme des gens qui disent on
veut maintenant aux affiches bien sûr
chantôme et enfin il a 12 qui font une
carrière professionnelle donc c'est une
grande satisfaction pour moi j'ai fait
une école de journalisme
oui c'était dpj
pendant deux ans et puis je travaille un
petit peu vain j'ai travaillé pendant
très longtemps et non comme consultant
pour des chaînes radio télé puis je
continue encore aujourd'hui
voilà mes mots c'est vrai que là la
reconversion c'est un sacré qu'est ce
que j'aimerais c'est qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
parce qu'on peut pas rester comme ça
rien faire regarder les scouts
normandeau ne vient de s'évanouir dans
autre chose et puis de trouver sa voie
et c'est ce qui est plus difficile c'est
de véritablement
trouver la bonne opportunité puis et
lequel avoir des envies dans lesquelles
on va vraiment s'épanouir pleinement
alors vous avez monté une société avec
un associé qui se veulent bien de
nouvelles oui tout à fait sa place en
guerre un sport et les gs alors c'est
cette société qui consiste en quoi
qu'est-ce qu'elle organise arias il ya
trois filières principales on organise
des événements relations publiques sur
des événements sportifs existants donc
on emmène des gens de société sur des
événements
dans différents sports le foot
évidemment particulier mais ça peut être
rugby le tennis et d'autres sports et
puis après deuxième secteur
bah c'est plus de la création
d'événements tour qui ont un trait au
sport donc on fait des journées golfique
avec des sociétés des personnalités
enfin tournoi de football aussi à 5
trophée des légendes dans trop de
twilight c'est ton le ton à des gens
c'est thomas des légendes où on associe
un milieu de l'entreprise est une
association qui est un ballon pour
l'insertion c'est une association qui
s'occupe des sans abri et puis on
introduit un ancien joueur professionnel
dans chaque équipe qui participent à
cette journée
c'est très festif et bien troisième un
univers ont fait du séminaire du team
building la soirée événementielle voir
voilà un petit peu les trois filières un
quart de travail
donc vous êtes heureux oui bah oui et
c'est heureux avec ses activités
multiples effectivement je reviens un
dernier mot sur le vous avez été un des
joueurs emblématiques
on dit parfois que le nouveau paris
saint-germain oublie un peu le passé on
avait vu ce matin à utiliser avant nous
il n'y a rien eu quoi et certains disent
au fond dans les grands clubs comme le
barça comme le real ya dans ce style
grands joueurs qui sont là pour
représenter le club pour en être
l'ambassadeur si on vous proposait une
fonction comme ça ça vous verrez travail
bien sûr un vrai évidemment en courant
foncez ça manque d'abord oui je pense
que c'est ça manque clairement au club
je pense que ça manque d'identité et
pour la crédibilité dans différents
postes que les univers peuvent être très
large dans un club je pense que c'est
important d'avoir cette légitimité
d'avoir des anciens joueurs ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau des plus jeunes par rapport
aux parents de pouvoir parler évidemment
de choses que je connais bien je
souhaitais professionnels c'est toujours
important d'avoir cette image et et de
devoirs en tout cas
à voir cette crédibilité par rapport à
ses parents qui peuvent évidemment
inscrire leurs jeunes mais c'est un
juste un pan dans divers secteurs du
club des besoins des besoins d'anciens
joueurs ce que je pense que dans les
instances aussi et ça c'est important
c'est pas très important janvier un
petit peu au golf dans un album à la
ryder cup
un superbe événement le parcours du golf
national
c'est quand on est un grand sportif
comme vous par exemple c'est quelque
chose qui vous excite bike complètement
cette veine des premières grandes
manifestations golfique international
enfin pour moi je vais découvrir donc je
trépignais un peu d'impatience de voir
tous ces grands joueurs et cet événement
arrivée en france et non très bientôt je
serai pas au niveau pour lui confie
alors je réponds à ce niveau là mais
sera intéressant de voir justement les
pratiques des baies très grands joueurs
pour pouvoir un petit peut signifier
pour réussit habituellement wifu de
regarder de temps en temps c'est
intéressant les comportements merci
infiniment vincent clerc six batteries
les locaux lui donc avoir votre société
et à vous merci
après bientôt
[Musique]
l'actrice laetitia fourcade la
journaliste de canal plus astrid bard et
le plus célèbre des gardiens de but
jérôme alonzo sont les trois parrain de
cette nouvelle édition des balles
blanches
c'était le 6 juin dernier au golf du cre
et sous l'oeil de son directeur jean
françois molina et du président et
organisateur des balles blanches
eric guesde l'organisent avec une
soixantaine de personnalités du monde du
sport spectacle et autres une
compétition où on fait venir une
trentaine d'enfants de différents
milieux hospitalisés spitalier par
contre pour financer différents projets
pour améliorer le quotidien des enfants
hospitalisés
quelques heures plus tard on pouvait
admirer le swing de jérôme alonzo ou
celui d'un autre footballeur bauchet
cette fois le grand vincent guérin
il ya la cause qui fait que ce toutes
ces personnalités se mobilisent
on a aussi des comédiens comme bruno
solo dany boon on a pas mal de belles de
belles personnalités qui viennent mais
c'est vraiment le coeur qui parle
d'abord disons qu'en fait cette démarche
c'était surtout pour montrer le sérieux
de l'association est vraiment démontré
que ben en fait on peut nous faire
confiance pour des projets mais les
balles blanches c'est d'abord toute une
journée inoubliable pour des enfants
dont le quotidien est celui de l'hôpital
et ils viennent ils arrivent sont un
petit peu apprécié au nez on voit pas
beaucoup de sourires et en fait au fur
et à mesure de la journée ils voyent de
nombreuses personnalités et en organise
différents différentes activités pour
pour eux et donc leurs partisans la
banane et au premier virage y dorment
pas ce qu'ils ont ils ont passé une
journée extraordinaire ici ils sont au
traîneau ou alors ils s'adonnent à la
création picturale
ils font jouer leurs muscles ou toc même
de s'adonner au tennis de table le golf
au service d'une cause humanitaire c'est
cela la philosophie des balles blanches
yes
[Musique]
alors je suis sur un engin formidable je
suis ravi de vous présenter s'appelle le
golf board
ça va révolutionner amont et fils le
golfe et je vais en parler avec son
importateur en france qui s'appelle
monsieur bâti alors je suis encore tout
à fait tout à fait à l'aise encore dans
le maniement des attentats mais c'est
extrêmement stable ça c'est formidable
et alors ça va permettre évidemment si
une alternative à la voiture quoi une
alternative à la voiture mais pas qu'une
attaque et aussi à la à la marche que le
golvan dresse aussi un sport on associe
un sport de glisse avec notre sport le
golf c'est un oui c'est un peu ça alors
c'est adapté du du snowboard ne peut
alors snowboard skate jusqu'à on ressent
vraiment les sensations de glisse mais
sur la pelouse sur le fairway alors
quand je disais que ça allait
révolutionner le golfe
on a fait des calculs nous avait fait
des calculs ça permet de faire un
parcours de 18 trous assez rapidement
alors on augmente la fréquence de
journée des tests qui ont été faits qui
nous permettent aujourd'hui de faire 18
trous en deux heures et demie en 2h30
alors c'est assez facile vous me ferez
de démonstration à près de manille mots
mais si on se penche à gauche on va à
gauche si on se penche à droite on va à
watts et puis on peut arrêter
d'accélérer quand on veut donc y'a rien
aucun risque alors aucun risque n'a été
étudié pour est totalement sécurisé il
est quatre roues motrices un pontault
bloquant qui permet de ne pas descendre
et ne va ne va monter tout seul il faut
quoi deux trois trous pour pour
maîtriser l'engin quoi selon les
personnes selon les personnes
c'est être 4 patrice - ouais je vais
peut-être aller dans l'eau là mais bon
c'est pas très grave qu alors un goût
cet engin qui c'est qui est donc le
golborne
vous allez le louer en leasing à des
clubs de golf
oui et ensuite les golfeurs vont louer
comme convenu une voiture tout à fait ça
sera vraisemblablement au prix d'une
voiture est au près d'une voiture est
évidemment c'est à la fois ludique et à
la fois belle ça permet de jouer plus
vite alors là faut être souple parfois
au plat alors là
quand on est mal on s'arrête regardez là
je suis dans la ponte oui alors on a une
marche arrière c'est quand on est comme
ça qu en fait regarder patrice je vais
faire une marche arrière en m'inclinant
un petit peu pour retourner je vais
m'arrêter s'arrête tout seul je repasse
la marche avant et je me remets dans le
sens du fairway
hopla moi j'ai failli faire une bêtise
mais alors c'est très simple celui
arrêté vous avez vous appuyez vous
n'accélérez plus donc le truc s'arrête
et une stabilité à toute épreuve quoi
c'est absolument incroyable
1 oui oui c'est ça a été étudié pour
pour le golfeur soit vraiment sécurité
en toutes situations que ce soit en
montée ou en descente voleur va
s'arrêter dès qu'on lâche l'accélérateur
n'en sécurité sur la planche ces faits
pour tous les parcours que les parcours
soit plat ou que le parcours soit aux
remontées en descente a fait là où passe
la voiturette le golgotha sera certes
pas seulement étudié pour tous les
parcours s'étudier pour tous les
golfeurs sert les seniors et les jeunes
veulent utiliser en toute sécurité
alors ce qu'on peut penser c'est comme
c'est très ludique quand même ça ajoute
un s'ajoute à un moment de l'unique
ludique euros à la pratique de boeuf
ça va peut-être ramener une bande et du
golfe à de nouvelles clientèles
une nouvelle démographie du golfeur
c'est vrai qu on dépoussière un petit
peu l'image négative à tort de notre
sport on espère que le goal board va
mener de plus de jeunes joueurs avant la
ryder cup
alors si si on veut voir convention
fonctionne vous avez un site un oui tout
à fait on a notre site donc golborne
lepoint.fr vous êtes toutes les vidéos
démonstrative extra succès en formule 1
sur les réseaux sociaux les clients qui
nous les gaules board se prennent en
vidéo et les postes donc sur les lieux
connus et vous pouvez voir donc des
personnes anonymes utiliser le golfeur
de manière tout à fait tout à fait
ludique
alors pour parler les golfeurs soient
déçus évidemment vous n'êtes pas encore
dourdan dans tous les golfs en france on
peut donner à peu près nous vous avez
vous avez l'idée de conclure les
premiers call box euros seront alloués
pour l'instant nous sommes en
en road show avec la lâcheté machine
jusqu'à mi juillet je pense qu'à partir
de début août vous pourrez tester le
goal bord donnant dans plusieurs golfs
en france et vous serez tenus informés
de de l'évolution de du golborne qu'elle
irait pas encore en france il y en a aux
etats unis aujourd'hui à 3000 bol d'or
qui circulent sur plus de 300 courses
dans le monde
on a notamment placé dans le goal de 512
en écho ce prix la mecque du golf
oui donc voilà c'est passé pas contre le
golf pression on respecte les traditions
du du golfe on ajoute juste une touche
un petit peu fun
fun à savoir que le goal bord tu
respectes également le ferro ils abîment
beaucoup moins ce qui ne veut qu'une
voiture est donc un chariot manuel est
d'ailleurs des green keeper des
décideurs peuvent peuvent se servir du
bruit dans ta fille il étudié ont donc
on a des pour mettre des graines ou du
sable on a des systèmes de rangement pru
gamekeeper puisse prendre soins de santé
alors un mot sur la technologie parce
qu'elle est extrêmement moderne
ce sont des moteurs électriques il se
recharge très vite alors tentant de
charge deux heures autonomy 24 heures
selon les conditions
terrain gras terrain vallonné poids du
golfeur on peut faire minimum 36 trous
avec a joué pas mal et ce sont des
ingénieurs très très près doué 1 alors
c'est l'ingénierie loto de l'industrie
automobile américaine inscrit de l'us
pour ne pas la citer patrick mignon qui
respectent l'environnement
donc c'est écologique c'est ludique et
en charge un peu la pratique du golf
c'est très amusant à conduire c'est très
facile j'arrive presque maintenant comme
si c'était un pro tout à fait jason
vargas et donc c'est formidable
donc on vous souhaite pas une grande
réussite en france parce que je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui va un peu
changer de lit disait la vie des
golfeurs merci beaucoup pâti en fin de
journée en asie
[Musique]
c'est l'homme en forme du moment il a
prouvé sur les grilles du golf national
tommy fleetwood de 26 ans 4e du dernier
us open a remporté la 101e édition de
l'open de france
pour sa cinquième apparition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la première
depuis 2010 le fantasque britannique
totalise un score de moins 12 au total
avec une carte de 66 soit cinq coups
sous le par le dimanche
je pense que c'était vraiment important
de bien jouer cette semaine
tout le monde a joué un très bon niveau
pour avoir un bon résultat
le parcours était très agréable et cela
m'a permis d'avoir un swing très
performant
un swing qui lui a permis de devenir le
premier anglais à remporter l'open de
france depuis 2007 et la victoire de
graines storm
une performance saluée par les milliers
de spectateurs venus pour profiter du
spectacle le dimanche je pense c'est un
joueur dont on entendra beaucoup parler
dans le futur magnifique
super joueur ces nouvelles générations
qui arrivent et ils sont super travers
du côté des tricolores on l'attendait le
meilleur français au classement mondial
alexander levy où l'imprévisible victor
dubuisson c'est finalement michael
lorenzo vera qui a réalisé la meilleure
performance des bleus sur le parcours de
l'albatros avec un moins huit au total
un score qui lui permet de terminer
troisième du tournoi est de se qualifier
pour le british open une première pour
le basque de 32 ans qui avait du bon
golf bonne attitude et de deux voiles à
toto qui a bien connu une belle partie
en plus ce dimanche avec les oiseaux de
ça c'est cool
santander on joue bien et 2 donc ça fait
bien plaisir puisque vraiment là les
gens étaient des emplois depuis le début
de la semaine
chaque fois que toujours des mots
gentils ni toujours vraiment des
amoureux
après cette troisième place michael
lorenzo-vera voulait succéder à thomas
levet l'année prochaine sur le golf
national
le dernier vainqueur français à l'open
de france et est en 2011
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour notre premier swing de champion de
l'année nous avons choisi le joueur
français en forme du moment michael
lorenzo vera michael c'est la machine à
swing et du golf français c'est mr
souhait son entraîneur benoît du
colombier en parle en termes très
élogieux
michael ces grippes parfait posture
parfaite parfaite coordination
le tout au service d'un rythme
parfaitement harmonieux regardons
ensemble ce qui dans le swing de michael
lorenzo vera peut nous aider à améliorer
notre pratique quotidienne
une organisation idéale devant la balle
c'est un dos plat des appuis vers
l'avant des chaussures par les abdos et
vers la balle
l'aplomb de l'arrière de l'épaule
passant par le boudu grippe devant les
genoux et le milieu des lacets on
retrouve la coordination du backswing de
michael dans cette illustration on doit
imaginer ici un vinyle ou le centre
serait le corps et l'extérieur la tête
de club on voit ici que le corps les
mains et la tête de clubs fonctionnent
ensemble tout le début du bac swing de
manière coordonnée la tête de club va
plus vite que les mains et les mains
plus vite que le corps de cette manière
vers le sommet de l'élan l'épaule gauche
les mains et la tête de clubs sont
encore en train de bouger ensemble pour
compléter le sommet de l'élan si on
s'intéresse ici à sa reprise d'appui
vers la cible harmonieusement son épaule
gauche son genou gauche reprenne la
direction de la cible en se dissociant
du menton le corps a repris sa position
centrale mais le côté gauche tout en
avançant ne vient jamais frappé dans le
mur imaginaire de l'extérieur du pied
gauche l'épaule droite prend le relais
pour venir frapper au niveau du point
bas dans un swing complètement centrer
et coordonnée
l'épaule droite ne cesse jamais d'avancé
pour se stabiliser
simplement au finish on est l'inversé
une posture juste et engager un bac
swing ou la tête de clubs les mains et
le dos rond parfaitement coordonné une
transition épaule gauche genou gauche
idéal jusqu'au mur imaginaire de la
plante du pied gauche
line épaule droite qui joue un rôle
prédominant dans la traversée dans le
follow through michael c'est un vrai
swing des champions
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]